tyler malley the righty will face the
cubs tonight donning the 42
on his jersey hoping to get into some
kind of a rhythm i think mali is
ian happ in the box in the first pitch
from mali is a swing
and into left field that is jesse winker
one pitch
one out maybe the cubs have been a
little too passive
when we talk so much about their patient
approach might pay off to be a little
more aggressive
anthony rizzo swings away and hits a
high drive
to right and two pitches in it's one to
nothing
as you were saying yeah i think i think
maybe
that's the game plan uh let's go up
there and look for a first pitch
fastball
trying to do some damage half had a good
swing didn't get the uh
result rizzo did a no doubter in the
cubs draw first blood
his sixth of the year well that ball was
up two
o'malley goes to work against javier
baez
foul tip into the mid of barnhart down
goes baez
schwarber has had success against mali 4
out of 11 with a home run and three
walks
waits on a 2-2 and a high fly ball
deep left and this one will go it's two
to nothing
[Music]
how about that kyle schwarber goes the
other way
and uh he likes hitting in cincinnati
wilson contreras
kyle hendricks a one two three first and
now he'll get four
five and six for the rent suarez
mustakas matt davidson
suarez gets under it did he get enough
at the wall go well we talked about
suarez heating up
little by little and he goes yard again
number seven red's on the board
but we can just switch our our
conversation
to exit below and launch angle
and i mean another fastball it looks
like a little sinker on the inner part
of the plate he gets that one
down and suarez likes him in there man
2-1 cubs bottom of the fourth winker to
lead off for the reds
the 0-1 pitch winker high
fly ball right field that bad boy is
gone hottest hitter in baseball number
nine how about you winker
and we are tied at two that'll put some
enthusiasm in that dog got a little
change up right there by kyle
hendrickson
i mean when you're seeing it as big as
winker that doesn't fool you one bit all
you do
is count to two and swing and now suarez
suarez left center field this one
will one hop off the wall and
suarez strolls into second base with his
third double of the season
davidson hit the ball hard first time up
base hit suarez on his way to third
they're going to wave him around
hayward throw in off and the reds have
the lead
one and two the count on victor caratini
swing and a miss
man that's a good splitter there filthy
splitter
eight strikeouts now for mali jason
kipnis
struck out in the second best ball
see you later 95 mile per hour heater
from mali
second and third two outs for suarez
suarez two for two
home run double he has scored twice
and here's a little flare and this one
will fall
one run scores here comes winker to the
plate and suarez is three for
three and the reds have a 5-2 lead
inning number six tyler malley after
giving up two in the first has settled
in
and now javier baez did he go
he did maui with 10 strikeouts
it's his third career double digit
strikeout game
payoff pitch swing and a miss how about
tyler malley 11 strikeouts
the five batter wilson contreras to lead
off for the cubs here in the seventh
high drive to center field akiyama
deepest part of the park
and a long loudout here comes david bell
two outs into the seventh good night for
mali
call to the bullpen it is amir garrett
the lefty
right on first base two outs swing
and a miss garrett all kinds of fired up
stretch time at gabp garrett bringing
some emotion to the game
all right inning number eight amir
garrick david bell puts him back out
there
anthony rizzo one out one on on the
ground
could be two on to first base
that's a double play amir
garrett pitcher's best friend that's
your old six
five three inning ender we head to the
bottom of the eighth
red still lead the cubs five to two kyle
ryan the only left-hander that they have
in their bullpen on here to face freddie
galvez here's the pitch to galvez
and he sends a fly ball to right field
hit pretty well still carrying backing
up hayward
he's at the wall and looks up it is gone
freddie galvez got it out of here to
right and for freddie galvez it's his
sixth home run of the year
this is robert stevenson pitching change
two strikes to contreras
out into deep left center for contreras
and it is gone
a two run homer
so the cubs have played it five in the
ninth over the last two games
and they're within two to hayward and
they're not done yet
hayward deep right gone
six to five what a night for hayward
how long is david bell going to wait
as it's now a 6'5 game and the reds have
called upon reisel iglesias to close
this one down
1-0 pitch
left field winker there
two outs two balls one strike on victor
caratini
ground ball galvest
and that'll do it it gets harry in the
ninth
but in the end it's a w for the reds as
they win their third straight overall
and take game one of this four-game set
against division rival
chicago cubs